[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covin 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire le monde
médical mais aussi les ex ministres et
directeurs généraux à de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de marisol
touraine ministre de françois hollande
2012 à 2017
au coeur du débat les stocks de masques
et la pénurie au moment de l'épidémie
lakovic 19 a provoqué une crise
sanitaire sans précédent dans notre pays
pour ne rien dire de ses conséquences
économiques
il est évidemment légitime de se
demander si la france était prête à
affronter une telle épidémie
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente
j'ai été ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé pendant cinq ans et je
veux témoigner de la priorité que j'ai
accordé sans relâche à la sécurité et à
la protection de tous nos concitoyens
dans toutes les circonstances de leur
vie y compris dans les moments de crise
les stocks stratégiques je ne doute pas
que nous y consacrerons un temps
important ne se limite pas aux masques
ne se limitait pas et ne se limite
toujours pas aux masques et des
décisions importantes ont été prises
pour d'autres produits
je veux insister sur le fait que des
commandes de renouvellement ont été
passées chaque année par la direction
générale de la santé dont j'ai eu à
connaître pour certaines sur les masques
à ce stade je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas
eu de changement de doctrine entre 2012
et 2017 que nous nous sommes inscrits
dans le cadre de la nouvelle doctrine
définie par le haut conseil de santé
publique en 2011 que rien ne m'a paru
justifier de remettre en cause
je me suis évidemment posé la question
il y avait sept cent trente millions de
masques chirurgicaux à mon arrivée 754 à
mon départ un effort spécifique a été
fait pour renforcer nos capacités
pédiatrique dans d'autres domaines aussi
d'ailleurs puisque 40 millions de
masques ont été achetés à cet effet
ces masques étaient à destination de la
population générale
il ne comportait pas de date de
péremption aucune alerte n'est jamais
remonté sur ce point les évaluations
postérieur
ont montré qu'ils pouvaient d'ailleurs
être largement utilisés par le grand
public
les stocks des masques ffp2 comportant
tous une date de péremption se sont
logiquement réduit au fil de l'eau
puisque la doctrine de 2011
on avait très drastiques très
drastiquement pardon limiter les cas
d'utilisation
merci madame la ministre avant de vous
passer la parole au rapporteur je vais
vous interroger sur deux points
premièrement en tant qu'ancienne
ministre de la santé quelle est votre
appréciation de la gestion de la crise
due qu'au guide
quels sont selon vous les points forts
les points forts et les points faibles
dans la réponse question des masques
dépistage vous l'avez abordé
organisation du système de soins par
exemple est la deuxième de mes questions
le plan de prévention et de lutte
pandémie grippale du sgdsn n'a pas été
actualisé depuis 2011 des stocks
stratégiques des masques mais aussi deux
médicaments sont procurés
progressivement arrivés à péremption
peut-on considérer que les enjeux de
préparation de crises sanitaires sont
passés au second plan au cours de la
décennie qui vient de s'écouler
je vous remercie madame la présidente ce
sont deux questions évidemment de nature
très différente je vous le disais à
l'instant il me paraît difficile de
porter un jugement lorsque l'on est de
l'extérieur sur la gestion d'une crise
aussi difficile aussi inattendu aussi
massive
je veux insister sur le fait que lorsque
j'étais ministre
je voulais dit j'ai été confronté à
toute une série de crises d'intensités
différentes et à l'évidence aucune n'a
atteint l'intensité de celle que nous
connaissons que nous traversons
aujourd'hui vous m'avez dit madame l'a
interrogé pardon madame la présidente
sur la gestion des stocks au fond et la
péremption des stocks pendant la période
2012 2017
les stocks stratégiques comporte des
dizaines de produits certains sont
assez simple à manipuler d'autres
beaucoup moins
certains peuvent être présentées de
manière très transparente à l'ensemble
de la population
d'autres beaucoup moins et sont classés
sous un régime de confidentialité
défense puisque ils doivent nous
permettre de faire face à d'éventuelles
attaques terroristes
ces stocks étaient gérés d'abord par
l'eprus puis par l'eprus au sein de
santé publique france par un spécialiste
qui est un pharmacien en chef qui
suivait la situation de manière
extrêmement direct des remontées de des
quantités de stocks
enfin des quantités de stocks remontait
au niveau de la dgs une fois tous les
trois mois il y avait des commandes de
renouvellement qui étaient passés tous
les ans pas au bout de cinq ans il y a
des commandes qui étaient passés tous
les ans sur un certain nombre de
produits et je pourrais vous donner des
documents qui montrent que 2014 2015
2016 c'est en général au début de
l'année que cela se passait 17 mars 2015
programmation d'acquisition en
antibiotiques et en antidote pour
l'année 2015 signé par le directeur
général de la santé 22 février 2016
acquisition de toujours du directeur
général de la santé acquisitions dans le
cadre du renouvellement du stock
stratégique lancement de la
programmation 2016 je vous évite la
lecture de la liste des produits qui est
toute une série de produits
médicamenteux dont je ne suis pas
certaine qu'il dise quelque chose à tous
ceux qui sont autour de cette table mais
qui hélas quelques jours plus tard
d'ailleurs cette liste est complétée
acquisitions dans le cas du
renouvellement du stock stratégique
lancement complémentaire de la
programmation 2016 je vous demande de
bien vouloir acquérir
on a des éléments extrêmement précis qui
sont donnés à chaque fois la mise en
place de vitry-le-françois des entrepôts
de vitry-le-françois dont vous avez déjà
entendu parler a été un élément
absolument décisif de la stratégie mise
en place entre 2012 et 2017 pour à la
fois concentré rationaliser sécuriser le
maintien des stocks de nature différente
si vous n'en avez pas encore vu des
photos je vous invite à voir les photos
parce que ces photos montrent des
établissements qui sont tout sauf ça le
laisser-aller qui montre qu'il y ait
tenu une organisation une gestion alors
dans cette période là dans cette période
là il y a eu des alertes particulière et
je veux insister parce que je me suis
préoccupé des stocks stratégiques dès
mon arrivée pour deux raisons la
première c'est que nous sortions d'achat
n si j'ose dire est que j'étais à
l'époque je siégeais à l'époque sur
vauban et j'avais eu à connaître de
cette crise nous avions eu avec certains
à en discuter et donc avant même 2012 la
question de savoir comment nous pouvions
gérer des stocks
et s'il était nécessaire d'avoir des
stocks importants s'étaient posés
notamment pour les vaccins la deuxième
raison pour laquelle j'ai été amené à
regarder cette question des stocks
à mon arrivée c'est que le directeur
général de la santé de l'époque que vous
avez auditionné jean yves grall m'avait
fait une note dans le dossier ministre
comme on dit pour m'indiquer l'évolution
de la doctrine 2011 et la question des
strophes des stocks leur gestion etc
j'ai eu donc j'ai eu à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions moi et c'est
pour cela que je vous disais qu'il y à
une chaîne de commandement clair on
n'est pas dans un système et je le dit
temps plus que je trouverai dommageable
pour nos concitoyens qu'ils aient le
sentiment que sur des sujets aussi
importants aussi sensible on ne sait pas
qui fait quoi si on sait qui fait quoi
il y a des gens qui prennent des
décisions évidemment une ministre ne va
pas compter les ampoules à
vitry-le-françois
je vous le confirme une ministre ou un
ministre d'ailleurs ne regarde pas
l'état des palettes et s'appuie sur des
personnes compétentes en qui elles
placent sa confiance directeur général
de la santé un opérateur qui a la
responsabilité de la gestion et qui
s'appuie sur un pharmacien en chef mais
une ministre elles montrent les
orientations elle prend des arbitrages
et elle est amenée à certains moments à
poser des questions et à regarder sur
certains sujets qui lui sont posées
quelle est la position qu'elle prend et
j'ai été amené madame la présidente à
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
je pense que c'est suffisamment
important pour que je vous les indics
très rapidement si vous avez ensuite des
compléments à me demander je le ferai
premièrement lorsque je suis arrivé on
me dit il y a eu un changement de
doctrine en 2011
la question que je pose c'est cette
doctrine est elle bonne cette doctrine
est elle adaptée et dont les discussions
tout cela ne fait pas l'objet de deux
notes de choses particulièrement
formalisé on me dit il y à une
alternative qui est le passage compte
tenu de la lourdeur de la gestion des
stocks
le passage à ce qu'on appelle une
doctrine de stock tampon c'est à dire
que au lieu d'avoir une cible qui est la
plus élevée possible je reviendrai sur
ce point là des centaines de millions
voire un milliard de masques on se dit
qu'après tout on pourrait en avoir
quelques admettons 100 millions ou
quelques dizaines de millions
le chiffre n'est pas évoquée et puis on
s'assure que on va pouvoir monter en
puissance rapidement cette question là
elle a existé au sens où elle était
présente je ne sais pas comment vous le
dire elle faisait l'objet de discussions
de débats au sein la dgs au sein des des
équipes spécialisées
je n'ai jamais accepté cette doctrine
c'est à dire que alors même que l'on en
a qu'on l'a évoquée j'ai maintenu l'idée
qu'il fallait avoir des stocks
importants à seulement pour les masquer
je vais revenir dans un instant et c'est
la raison pour laquelle même si certains
d'entre vous vont dire mais pourquoi n'y
avait-il pas un milliard de masques et
il y en avait-il que 754 millions il y
avait celle 154 millions de masques à la
fin du mandat
la deuxième situation dans laquelle j'ai
été amené à prendre des décisions assez
rapidement et malheureusement les
processus sont l'antique et d'ailleurs
si je puis me permettre un élément de
réflexion avoir pour une commission
comme la vôtre
c'est la question de la disponibilité
des vaccins anti grippaux dont vous
trouverez d'ailleurs mention de cette
problématique dans le fameux rapport
delattre qui évoque de manière très
positive et louangeuse les démarches que
nous avons engagées à partir de 2013
la dgs la dgs et et moi même la question
c'est comment peut-on éviter d'avoir des
stocks précisément qu'ils soient trop
importants et ne peut-on pas passer par
des procédures de préachat qui que l'on
paie repérer à l'avance des stocks qui
nous seraient garanties au niveau
national ou au niveau européen au niveau
national nous n'avons pas je vais vite
donc nous n'avons pas trouvé le moyen de
faire nous avons eu des discussions avec
des entreprises très particulière et
nous nous sommes greffe et nous avons
intégré un programme d'action commun qui
est un programme européen qui nous
permet d'avoir donc de disposer
d'une garantie de doses de vaccins nous
faisons des prêts achats groupés au
niveau européen nous avons négocié je
voulais 10 à partir de 2013 l'accord est
passé en 2015
il fallait une autorisation du parlement
il a été ratifié au parlement en 2016 la
loi a été promulguée le 2 février 2017
et les appels d'offres lancés par
l'union européenne l'ont été début 2017
je n'en avais je comprends que les
premières procédures sont intervenus
assez nettement après c'est la lenteur
pas simplement national d'ailleurs mais
aussi européennes donc j'ai pris une
décision puisque je dois présenter un
texte de loi au parlement
lorsque le directeur général de la santé
qui avait en place toute une série de
procédures qui avait des réunions
mensuelles qui ne remontait pas moi mais
qu'il y avait des réunions mensuelles
avec l'ensemble des agences sanitaires
qui avait plusieurs fois par an des
réunions qui réunissait l'ensemble des
agences pas simplement les agences
sanitaires exclusivement sous le
contrôle du ministère de la santé mais
aussi les agences qui de près ou de loin
toucher à la santé par exemple hans hess
pour l'alimentation il y avait en
quelque sorte des coordinations agence
qui étaient réunis par monsieur benoit
valait à l'époque directeur général de
la santé et donc en 2016 fin 2016
il demande et commencent à lancer une
évaluation il vous a expliqué pourquoi
seulement à cette date on y revient et
il demanda santé publique france 2
regarder la doctrine et de faire des
propositions sur les quantités de
produits à avoir sur les masques sur les
antiviraux et sur les anti grippaux
voilà donc il y a eu toute une stratégie
qui a consisté à suivre de manière
extrêmement précise la situation
des stocks et je veux je reviendrai
peut-être sur le point qui a été évoquée
de 95 % de produits périmés parce qu'il
ya une explication que l'on peut donner
mais je ne veux pas être trop long merci
de temps que nous allons avoir pas mal
de questions monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
madame la ministre nous avons auditionné
c'était la première audition d'ailleurs
monsieur jérôme salle au mans l'actuel
directeur général de la santé qui a été
également votre conseiller et presse a
révélé dans les mails dit de la sphère
wikileaks que jérôme salomon avait écrit
aux candidats l'époque à l'élection
présidentielle emmanuel macron une note
d' alerte au demeurant très prémonitoire
et qu'on pourrait résumer en quelques
mots la france n'est pas prête pour
affronter une crise sanitaire notamment
d'évoquer d'autres crimes mais notamment
une crise sanitaire majeure
monsieur salle au mans je crois a été
votre conseiller membre de votre cabinet
est ce qu'il vous a alerté d'abord quel
rôle jouez au sein de votre cabinet est
ce qu'il vous a alerté sur cette
impréparation enfin sur ce sentiment sur
cette analyse qui aujourd'hui
rétroactivement apparaît malheureusement
très très pertinente est ce qui vous a
alerté est ce que vous avez senti cette
analyse comme une forme de critique de
ce qu'ils avaient pu être fait dans la
préparation sur sur les cinq premières
années
première question la seconde
vous nous avez indiquée je crois que
c'est assez précis et et vous ils vous
démontrer en tout cas là la maîtrise de
la connaissance parfaite des dossiers et
je crois que cette maîtrise est démontre
que vous êtes allé au fond du regard sur
les évaluations le renouvellement des
stocks notamment stratégiques de l'état
que vous avez voulu maintenir et les
chiffres que vous citez à peu près le
même nombre de masques chirurgicaux et
ffp2 parce que les ffp2 eux ont
quasiment disparu
sur la période de 380 millions à 700
milles mais vous vous démontrez un
regard assez précis donc est ce que vous
aviez comment avez-vous ce regard sur
les stocks stratégiques qui relevait
d'abord l'eprus ensuite de centrer
public france quand il a intégré l'eprus
est ce que vous aviez des notes de santé
publique france adressé qui vous étaient
adressées directement elle ce qu'elle
était adressée à votre directeur de
cabinet est-ce que vous avez évoqué ses
stocks dans les réunions sans doute
hebdomadaires entre vos cabinets votre
cabinet ou peut-être présidée par vous
même je sais pas comment ça se passait
mais est-ce que vous êtes vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et on le comprend que
vous n'êtes pas allés vérifier les
flacons le comté haut rhin le nombre de
masques mais j'imagine que d'autres
l'ont fait et est ce que ces
informations vous sont remontés est ce
que vous les avez contrôle évalué c'est
ce que vous sembliez dire dans votre
propos liminaire des ans j'ai voulu
maintenir
voilà est-ce que vous vous avez us ce
regard à la fois pro prévisionnel et
exhaustif sur l'état des lieux de des
stocks des stocks de masques et puis
troisième question au niveau des moyens
tactiques vous évoquez la nouvelle la
circulaire deux aiguilles et bertrand de
novembre 2011 qui fait la distinction
entre les moyens tactiques et et les
stocks stratégiques moyens tactiques
mises en place dans les samu dans les
dents l'exclure dans les établissements
de santé
est-ce que comment on a vérifié puisque
bon c'est la fin de l'année 2011 c'est
presque l'alternance comment ces moyens
tactiques c'est une question qu'on a
souvent posé et qu'on se pose toujours
sans de véritables réponses ont été
évalués au cours de la période
est ce qu'il ya eu un contrôle des ars
est-ce que les ars ou le ministère ou la
dgs a dit dans chaque établissement il
faut telle composition des moyens
dactique est ce qu'il y avait les
masques dans ses moyens dactique
certaines des gestes nous ont dit
pouvait y être il pouvait ne pas y être
il n'était pas prévu au départ
quelle est l'évaluation initiale des
moyens tactiques qu'il faut dans chaque
établissement
et surtout quel est le contrôle sur la
période
est ce qu'on vérifie que le chu de nice
a bien à bien ces masques ou que voilà
sur la période bon ce qui semblait pas
être complètement le cas au début de nos
débuts de la crise voilà un peu le pour
l'instant c'est 3-3 question madame le
ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
essayer d'y répondre de la manière la
plus complète et concise possible à la
fois jérôme salomon a été le conseiller
en sécurité sanitaire un excellent
conseiller
parfaitement au point sur les dossiers
c'était un spécialiste reconnu et
j'avais avec lui une relation de
confiance et il m'a épaulé dans un
toutes les crises que j'ai eu à
connaître pendant la période où il était
là c'est lui et avec lui c'est lui qui
m'a fait un certain nombre de
recommandations et c'est avec lui en
lien avec le directeur général de la
santé que nous avons profondément
transformé le paysage de la sécurité
sanitaire il m'avait d'ailleurs fait un
certain nombre de notes et ses notes se
sont traduites pour la plupart dans des
décisions des changements qui ont été
faits je vais les râper très rapidement
puisque j'ai déjà eu au fond l'occasion
de les évoquer
le premier c'est la création d'une
agence intégrée santé publique france
agence nationale de santé publique
pourquoi je vais très vite je les dis le
paysage sanitaire étaient éparpillés il
y avait parfois des doublons je ne parle
même pas des enjeux financiers ou
organisationnelles il y avait des
difficultés à coordonner la connaissance
scientifique
le travail de le travail de recherche le
travail de prévention l'élaboration des
messages la mise en place des données
opérationnelles en 2013 j'ai 2013 j'ai
confié une mission à deux personnes qui
étaient benoît valley qui arrivait comme
directeur général de la santé et
madame françoise weber qui avait été qui
était la présidente à l'époque où
directrice présidente je pense de la de
exécutive de liane vs l'institut
national de la veille sanitaire qui a
intégré santé publique france pour qu'il
me fasse un point sur ce qui existait à
l'étranger m'identifie les bonnes
solutions les mauvaises fallait les
différentes options et donc nous mettons
en place santé publique france deuxième
acquis de cette période le plan
l'organisation d'une réponse aux
situations d'urgence sanitaire aux
ressent j'insiste ça a été un point
majeur nous l'avons vous enfin le
gouvernement notre pays il a activé
pendant cette crise
or sans est décliné en 5 type en cinq
catégories de risques dont un risque
pandémique qui n'est pas le seul or sans
se met en place en 2014 il y à une
circulaire qui est envoyé par la dgs à
l'ensemble des agences régionales de
santé en leur disant c'est un travail
très lourd qui vous est demandé très
difficile c'est un bouleversement de
notre organisation mais je vous demande
de vous mobiliser parce que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important et
pour donner de la force à orsan jeunes
inscrits dans la loi de modernisation de
notre système de santé qui est débattu
au parlement en 2015 pub promulgué début
2016 et un décret d'application de cette
loi spécifique à orsan ait pris le 6
octobre suivant si un décret en conseil
d'état le 6 octobre 2016 qui permet de
définir de manière plus précise plus
rigolo va plus précises opérationnelle
la mise en oeuvre d'orsan et après ce
décret et parallèlement à ce décret il y
à un guide d'utilisation qui est envoyée
aux préfets et aux agences régionales de
santé sur la manière dont fonctionne
or sans les questions qu'il faut poser
la face on doit se nouer le dialogue
avec
les établissements de santé les
établissements médico sociaux et les
professionnels libéraux qui sont les
trois catégories qui systématiquement
son évoluer troisième mesures que nous
prenons
pendant cette période là c'est à la
suite d'un rapport de l'ancien directeur
général de la santé jean yves grall qui
rapport qui sort à la fin de l'année
2013 sur la réorganisation du système
d'alerté de vigilance nous mettons un
portail en place un portail unique dé
vigilance parce que jusque là c'était un
peu je ne dis pas que ça ne marchait pas
mais en tout cas ça n'était pas très
simple et pas très compréhensible j'ai
déjà parlé de la mise en place de la
plate forme de vitry le françois nous
créons et c'était d'ailleurs une
suggestion de jérôme salomon un poste de
directeur général de la santé adjoints
nommés en conseil des ministres chargés
de la coordination des agences
sanitaires ce qui montre bien que nous
avions cette volonté d'un travail
renforcé j'ai déjà évoqué les exercices
etc
alors nous avons fait tout cela quelle
est la question qui je n'en ai pas parlé
avec lui qui à mon avis taraude un peu
jérôme salomon au moment où il fait le
choix de soutenir la candidature
d'emmanuel macron c'est que la culture
de l'urgence la culture de l'exception
reste inégalement partagée et c'est
encore vrai aujourd'hui nos hôpitaux ont
montré leur savoir faire en matière
d'urgence et de réactivité
y compris au sein des agences régionales
de santé
elles n'ont pas toutes la même culture
et la même aptitude et je pense que la
préoccupation de jérôme salomon qui
d'ailleurs était la mienne et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous faisions des
exercices c'était non pas de s'assurer
que nous avions les moins
opérationnels disponibles mais que
chacun saurait s'en emparer de la même
manière au même moment et ça c'est
quelque chose
monsieur le rapporteur dont vous
m'accorderez que à tous les échelons de
la vie nationale ou peut avoir été
confronté à ce genre de problème est que
parfois on prend des décisions on prend
des exercices on donne des moyens et qu'
ils font une formes d'acculturation et
c'est vrai que nous avons une culture la
culture de l'urgence est une culture
très particulière et donc c'est pour ma
part en tout cas de cette manière là que
j'ai interprétés mais il faudrait lui
poser la question je crois que vous
l'avez fait d'ailleurs mais directement
la deuxième question que vous m'avez
posé monsieur le rapporteur
c'est sur les moyens stratégiques et
vous m'avez dit que dans la mesure où
j'avais eu connaissance d'un certain
nombre de situations concernant d'autres
stocks
il était légitime que de se demander si
j'avais eu des informations de même
nature sur les stocks stratégiques de
deux masques
il y avait effectivement des réunions
très régulière qui n'étais pas à mon
niveau mais dont j'avais connaissance
mais qu'ils n'avaient pas à mon niveau
il y avait une réunion mensuelle entre
mon directeur de cabinet le directeur de
santé publique france où auparavant le
directeur de l'eprus il y avait
évidemment des réunions
donc je ne peux pas vous dire la
fréquence mais à mon avis hebdomadaires
entre le directeur général de la santé
et les différents opérateurs de l'état
il y avait une réunion hebdomadaire si
ce n'est davantage avec le directeur
général de la santé et dans ces réunions
là il est arrivé qu'on me fasse remonter
un certain nombre de situations que je
vous ai évoqué mais à aucun moment je le
dis très sincèrement et très clairement
à aucun moment la question des masques
nommé remonté et je veux même ajouté qu'
elle ne met jamais comme on monte je
vais vous dire pourquoi elle ne m'a
d'ailleurs jamais été évoqué dans aucune
réunion internationale
il se trouve qu'au niveau international
comme je suis resté cinq ans il ya un
certain nombre de mes homologues que
j'ai fini par bien connaître et donc on
parlait c'est quoi tes problèmes etc etc
et donc et on s'apercevait d'ailleurs
qu'on avait souvent les mêmes c'est pas
tout à fait un hasard qu on était
confrontés aux mêmes défis
et sur la question des masques au fond
elle mais elle m'a été indiqué de la
manière suivante
nous n'avons pas besoin de maintenir des
masques ffp2 dans les stocks
stratégiques puisque ces masques sont
réservés à des actes pas simplement à
des professionnels mais à des actes
extrêmement limités et donc nous n'en
avons pas besoin
on peut d'ailleurs se poser la question
de savoir si il ne faudrait pas revoir
ce point là pour avoir un petit stock
tampon pour le coup mais deuxièmement on
m'a dit il n'y a pas de date de
péremption sur les masques et je me
permets d'ailleurs parce que moi j'ai
fait ma petite tournée quand même
lorsque tout cela est arrivé j'ai appelé
les hug appelé des collectivités locales
j'ai appelé
des entreprises il y avait des stocks de
masques je ne réponds pas encore à votre
troisième question mais il y avait des
stocks de masques qui pour certains
pardon je vais je veux juste vous
rappeler un petit peu principes de base
l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir des
informations pas forcément seulement de
poser des questions mais bien sûr madame
c prévenait alors si vous soyez un pic
de correct merci ne sont pas remontés là
ce qui m'a été indiqué c'est qu' il n'y
avait pas de date de péremption est que
dans la mesure où nous avions à faire
face à un certain nombre d'exigences
absolument indispensable ebola la
variole les stocks antigrippaux
antiviraux et bien l'analyse était que
avec 757 130 les années précédentes
730 millions de masques nous étions en
mesure de faire face et je me permets de
dire que peut-être que si nous avions eu
ces stocks là il y a quelques semaines
la situation aurait été en tout cas
psychologiquement à ces différentes sur
le troisième point les moyens tactiques
donc les moyens tactiques sont
effectivement concentré définies au
niveau des zones de défense est à dire
qu il y à un préfet et un à rs 2 en
responsabilité sur ses moyens tactiques
en lien avec ce qu'on appelle des
établissements de référence qui sont
principalement des chu des samu des smur
parfois des établissements médico
sociaux avec manuel valls alors ministre
de l'intérieur
j'ai pris une circulaire le 21 août 2013
qui permettent de définir le circuit de
distribution des produits de santé et
des masques toute une série d'actions
ont été menées au niveau de l'âge et de
la dgs pardon pas à mon niveau pour
informer les acteurs concernés et en
à partir de 2014 se met en place 1
système informatique qui s'appelle si
j'ai ce qui permet aux établissements de
renseigner sur les moyens dont il
dispose
ce qui est vrai c'est que ceux sur les
masses qui ne l'auraient pas imposer de
renseigner l'application et peuvent le
faire et un certain nombre d'entre eux
l'ont fait et en avril 2010 est peu
avant mon départ le directeur de santé
publique france françois bourdillon
adresse une note au directeur général de
la santé en réponse à une demande pour
lui faire le point sur l'état de
renseignement de l'application siges et
donne un avis qui est très positif je
pourrais si vous souhaitez vous
communiquer ce document merci nous
allons passer aux questions je vais
prendre et par groupes de trois donc
avec tout d'abord damien abad pour les
républicains
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
analyse un mot sur sur les masques ce
qu'en fait vous vous évoquez souvent le
changement de doctrine de 2011
en 2013 il est passé des choses en 2013
on a quand même le secrétaire-général la
défense la sécurité nationale qui
clairement dit un certain nombre de
choses sur la doctrine de protection des
travailleurs et la distinction notamment
dans les stocks stratégiques d'état les
moyens de tactique en région il ya une
circulaire qui a été prise le 11 juin
2013 dans la miss qui est une circulaire
également qui émane de votre ministère
moi je veux comprendre pourquoi d'abord
qu'est-ce qui vous empêchait si vous
pensiez qu'il fallait ces stocks est
reconstitué ses stocks et notamment sur
la ffp 2 qu'est-ce qui vous empêchait de
renouveler ses stocks de masques ffp2 et
sur les masques chirurgicaux vous dites
oui le stock est quasiment inchangé mais
les 100 millions de commandes annuel est
ce que vous pouvez nous préciser ce que
chaque année vous avez fait une commande
de 100 millions de masques ou pas on le
voit bien
vous avez vous même reconnu que des
interférences sur la ligne budgétaire
avec la question des mollahs avec les
attentes à 2015 avec l'acquisition des
antiviraux en 2016 donc dit nous
précisément qu'est ce que vous avez
commandé pourquoi on n'arrive pas à cet
objectif des 100 millions ça c'est sur
la question des masques deuxièmement sur
la question de santé publique france et
de la fin de l'épreuve est ce qu'un
moment donné vous vous conseillez vous
avez été alertés sur le fait que la
réserve sanitaire en france allait
dépendre de la chine
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
qui et qui revenu ou pas et c'est
quelque chose que finalement vous voilà
vous assumez ou pas parce qu'on a un
certain nombre de déclarations notamment
du sénateur delattre qui nous explique
que finalement on nous dit que la
réserve va dépendre des chinois mais que
tout ceci n'est n'est pas grave
et enfin dernière question plus sur les
ars et les ehpad vous avez dit vous
dénoncez le ars bashing notamment dans
cette crise et et dans le même temps
vous avez vous même demandé ce qui est
plus d'élus et de liens avec les élus
dans les ars
comment vous voyez cette organisation
territoriale de la santé et notamment le
lien entre les ars et les ehpad en
france merci boris malo pour les
socialistes
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre
le rapporteur a évoqué la note de
monsieur salomon qui avait été votre
conseiller qui deviendra directeur
général de la santé et est alarmante et
en effet il conclut de manière un peu
général sans distinction de sa gestion
des risques que le pays n'est pas prêt à
affronter un certaine angoisse de savoir
si vous partagez au moment où vous
quittez votre fonction le sentiment que
nous ne sommes pas prêts à affronter un
certain nombre des crises et en quoi
c'est un sentiment que partage et dans
la crise que nous avons connue ensuite
il y a des choses des choses qui étaient
qui n'est pas des choses des fire
voudrais en particulier avoir des points
de précisions sur on a du mal à
comprendre une doctrine d'emploi des
stocks stratégiques en 2011 sans y avoir
comme ça vient d'être évoqué un
changement de créneau 2013 en quoi
consiste-t-il et puis il semblerait
qu'il y ait eu mais de façon très
informelle un changement de doctrine en
2018 puisque une fois qu'il est constaté
l'ats
la non conformité des masques il ya la
destruction de 600 millions de masques
et une reconstitution très parcimonieuse
de 50 millions plus éventuellement 50
millions de masques est ce que ce type
d'information dont la ministre madame
blizzard nous a dit qu'elle n'avait pas
eu connaissance est ce que c'est le
genre de l'information nous paraît
constitutive d'un changement de doctrine
qu'une ministre en tout cas que vous
auriez demandé à vos collaborateurs de
porter à votre de porter à votre
connaissance et je voudrais de ce point
de vue là que vous puissiez clarifier
les responsabilités de chacun entre
santé publique france
la dgs et le mini série sans de
l'établissement de la doctrine des
stocks stratégiques
on n'a pas bien compris à qui
appartenait la définition de cette
doctrine est ce que c'est santé publique
france est ce que c'est la dgs est ce
que c'est la ministre et le sgdsn
n'avons pas entendu parler s'agissant de
merci jean christophe lagarde
si la présidente madame la ministre
votre mandature votre ministère est très
important puisque c'est le moment où
effectivement on change la doctrine de
la mettre en place et on doit vérifier
qu'elle fonctionne je voudrais d'abord
vous interroger sur la doctrine du sgdsn
de 2013 qui prévoit que désormais les
protections qu'ils sont pour les
salariés que ce soit des établissements
de santé ou non plus doivent être
constituées par les employeurs vous avez
à l'époque jérôme salomon comme
conseiller pour la sécurité sanitaire
il me semble qu'il est normal à ce
moment là pour mettre en place non
seulement les contrôles mais les
vérifications régulières de l'état de
ses stocks pas seulement dans les
hôpitaux mais chez les entreprises
participantes privé particulière est-ce
que vous avez mis un terme en place un
tel contrôle dans le privé et dans les
établissements de santé établissements
médico sociaux est ce que vous avez
donné aux instructions aux ars de le
faire est ce que comme la doctrine le
prévoyait normalement vous avez demandé
au préfet de zone de défense devrait
interroger un lors des auditions de
faire ces vérifications dans les
établissements de santé et chez les
employeurs et est ce qu on vous en a
rendu compte et ce qu'il reste des
traces de ces contrôles puisqu'en fait
on se serait rendu compte bien longtemps
avant qu'on était démuni un peu partout
dans le privé comme dans le public me
semble-t-il 6
ces contrôles avaient lieu le préfet des
hauts de france nous a dit qu'en fait
c'est contrôle n'avait pas eu lieu je ne
sais pas si il leur a été demandé
c'était ce qui m'intéresse c'est est de
votre responsabilité est ce que vous
pouvez me dire d'une façon générale si
le ministre de la santé mais ça rejoint
ce que disait brise allons donc je
m'étendrai pas à une vision de l'état
des stocks est ce qu'on l'a laërt est ce
qui vous arrive est d'échanger avec
monsieur g monsieur vallée sur le
suggère est-ce que sur l'acquisition
c'est suite à l'audition d'hier sur la
décision vous allez dire on acheter
régulièrement des stocks est ce que le
ministre de la santé est consulté son
lui fait valider est-ce qu'on lui monte
ou est-ce que c'est uniquement de la
responsabilité du ps
enfin vous avez dit qu'il ya eu des
exercices vous souvenez vous combien
quels ont été les conclusions on était
prêts on n'était pas prêts qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait corriger sur les
différents types mais particulièrement
sur ce qui vous a touché et je terminais
par monsieur simplement monsieur
simplement nous a dit qu'il a été amené
en 2018 il n'était plus sous votre
responsabilité de mettre hors service
600 millions de masques pour péremption
non-validité etc et il a pris la
décision de ne commander que deux fois
50 millions est ce que ça vous paraît
cohérent est ce que ça vous paraît
raisonnable
est-ce que c'était pas fait rare et
courir un risque inconsidéré aux
français d'être démuni en cas de crise
celle que nous venons d'avoir sous
prétexte de faire un stop dynamique dont
il me semble que vous avez commencé à
dire que c'était une discussion à
l'intérieur du ministère de la santé
déjà à votre époque
est ce qu'on faisait un gros stock parce
qu'on avait un stock tampon comptant sur
des pays étrangers pour nous fournir en
cas de besoin merci caroline fiat pour
la france insoumise
un merci madame la présidence en 2011
juste avant que vous deveniez ministre
de la santé la doctrine concernant les
stocks de masques a changé il était
désormais demandé aux hôpitaux d'avoir
des stocks tactique des masques ffp2 en
réserve en cas d'épidémie madame à nice
mme bisa nous expliquer qu'en janvier
dernier on n'était pas sûr que la
doctrine de 2011 avaient été comprises
et appliquées dans les hôpitaux des jeux
sites d'où la constitution d'un stock
d'état d'un million de masques ffp2 dans
la tente d'obtenir des remontées de
terrain
comment se fait-il que la ministre n'ait
pas eu l'assurance que la doctrine de
2011 était bien appliquée est comprise
quelle fut votre rôle dans ce changement
quelles recommandations ont été données
aux hôpitaux des mesures d'évaluation et
de contrôle ont-elles été mise en place
pour s'assurer que des stocks étaient
correctement constitué et permettrait
d'anticiper une éventuelle épidémie
lorsque vous avez quitté votre ministère
en 2017 vous affirmiez que 754 millions
de masques chirurgicaux et est en stock
comment cette information vous est elle
parvenue quel était l'état de ces
masques
par ailleurs il semblerait que sous
votre gouvernement des plus l'agencé
chargée de faire face aux épidémies
sanitaire en constituant des stocks
stratégiques de produits de santé comme
les familles mafieuses jco a vu ses
financements continué à fondre
l'établissement avait un budget de 280
millions d'euros en 2007 et seulement
25,8 millions en 2015
comment l'expliquez vous saviez vous que
les masques étaient en train de perry
mais ma dernière question c'est parce
que je ne pouvais pas passer à côté
durant votre prise de fonction ministère
vous avez fermé plus de quinze mille
lits d'hospitalisation complète
regrettez vous ce choix aujourd'hui
alors avant de passer la parole il faut
vous attendre à des réponses longues
lorsque vous posez 10 à 12 questions
chacun donc voilà je vous dis ça pour
les impatiences merci madame la
présidente j'ai compris le message
plusieurs questions se recoupent donc je
vais je vais essayer de
être la plus précise possible concise
possible il n'y a pas de changement de
doctrine en 2013 le secrétariat général
de la défense nationale de la sécurité
de la défense nationale pardon prend une
ce qu'il appelle une doctrine de
protection des travailleurs face aux
maladies hautement pathogène à
transmission respiratoire qui ne
changent pas la doctrine du haut conseil
pour la santé publique qui tire les
conséquences de deux choses c'est écrit
noir sur blanc dans le document qui tire
les conséquences du changement de
doctrine de 2011 qui réduit
drastiquement l'utilisation des masques
ffp2 et qui tire la conséquence
enfin qui rappelle les termes du code du
travail
l'article l 41,21 1-1 et l 41 21-2 issus
de l' ordonnance numéro 2000 7-3 129 du
12 mars 2007 qui fait porter la
responsabilité de la sécurité et de la
santé physique et psychologique des
travailleurs de leurs salariés aux
employeurs et donc c'est en faisant le
lien entre ces deux changements qui sont
tous les deux intervenus avant 2013
avant 2012 pardon que le sgdsn dit eh
bien il appartient aux employeurs au nom
de leur mission de leur responsabilité
de protection de leurs travailleurs de
leurs salariés de constituer les stocks
s'ils le souhaitent et d'ailleurs le
document est très intéressant puisque il
ne dit pas vous devez avoir ceci ou cela
il dit trois types de mesures sont
envisagées trois types de situation et
il dit l'employeur devra prendre des
mesures d'organisation nécessaires pour
que les travailleurs de soi en contact
avec des personnes à qui l'on aura
préalablement distribué des masques
anti-projections chirurgicaux et qui les
porteront effectivement donc qui met
toute une série
il appartient à l'employeur s'il le juge
utile de etc
donc il n'y a pas de changement de
doctrine à partir de là le sgdsn qui
comme vous le savez dépend du premier
ministre qui comme vous le savez dépend
du premier ministre demande à chaque
ministère de faire passer la consigne
pour le secteur qui est le sien donc il
ne m'appartenait pas de donner des
consignes aux entreprises privées
monsieur abad cela relevait de la
direction générale du travail dgt
ailleurs même si ça n'est pas dans mon
champ de compétence et était regardée
je ne sais pas ça a été fait mon choix
il ya un accusé de réception à l'issue
de ce de cette doctrine dont qui date du
21 mai 2013 je les ai déjà évoqué le
ministre de l'intérieur et moi même
manuel valls et moi-même prenons une
circulaire le 21 août 2013 à destination
des préfets de zone et des agences
régionales de santé en indiquant bien
justement que c'est désormais aux
établissements de santé pour ce qui nous
concerne que relève la compétence de
disposer des stocks de masques et la dgs
ça commence avec jean yves grall et là
c'est au niveau de la dgs que ça se
passe donc il se trouve que j'ai eu
accès à un certain nombre de documents
mais ce ne sont pas des documents qui
remonte à mon niveau
la dgs met en place toute une série de
deux procédures et cela débouche sur ce
que j'ai évoqués il ya un instant c'est
à dire la mise en place du système
d'information si j'ai ce qui permet de
renseigner pour s'assurer que les
établissements disposent des masques
dont ils ont besoin je tiens à dire que
d'ailleurs la plupart je ne dis pas 100%
je ne suis plus en responsabilité je ne
suis pas en mesure de donner des
statistiques précises quelqu'un m'a dit
80% mais peu importe que la plupart des
établissements de référence avait des
stocks de masques dans des quantités
assez variable c'est-à-dire que certains
avaient
deux mois de stock de deux mois de stock
en période normale
je veux dire par deux mois de stocks
d'autres avaient six mois de stock
certains même un an pas très nombreux la
moyenne le semblant s'établir autour de
deux mois parce qu'il y avait des
procédures d'achat qui tournait
régulièrement vous m'avez demandé
monsieur abad
si j'avais commandé les masques oui j'ai
commandé des masques je vous ai dit
jeudi deux choses la doctrine de 2011
elle ne parle pas d'un milliard de
masques mais nous avons toujours
considéré et j'ai toujours considéré je
vous le dis moi je fais pas j'ai
toujours considéré que nous devions
aller le plus haut possible vers un
milliard je vous dis pas que je me
levais tous les matins en disant un
milliard un milliard un milliard
non mais je ne vous dis pas je n'ai
jamais considéré que nous devions
réduire le nombre de masques donc
l'objectif c'était d'aller le plus loin
possible
il y a eu des interférences la plus
importante ça a été la variole et ebola
voilà les deux plus importantes pas les
seuls mais les deux plus importantes
donc nous avons fait rentrer 56 millions
de masques en 2014 20 millions de
masques adultes en 2015 je prends un
billet à date précise à 21 février 2014
20 mai 2015 20 millions de masques
adultes 39 millions
dans pardon 39 millions voilà et 20
millions de masques pédiatrique au total
140 voilà et ensuite en 2016 5 millions
+ 5 millions donc 140 millions de masses
qui nous amène à 754 est ce que vous me
dites 750 balle était est ce que vous le
dites vous trouvez que 750 754 la même
chose qu'un meilleur je vous réponds non
monsieur abattre je sais compter mais je
vous dis 754 c'est plus que 730 que
j'avais au départ et ça montre qu'il y a
eu une volonté il y a eu une volonté de
toujours aller le plus loin possible et
si nous n'avons pas encore une fois je
me répète mais si nous n'avons pas dit
il faut absolument pousser les feux
c'est parce que on me disait un il n'y a
pas de date de péremption et de avec 750
millions de masques
on est quand même par et on n'est pas
dans une situation où on est démuni pour
ce qui est des ffp2 c'est vrai que
l'attitude l'analyse a été différente
et mais jusqu'en 2016
il y a des ffp2 en stop puisque il ya ya
ya eu il ya une décrue au fil de l'eau
en fonction de la date de péremption
donc au fond jusqu'en 2016
on a des masques et je voudrais que vous
ayez conscience qu'en période normale
la consommation de de masques ffp2 elle
est relativement limité c'est moins de
10 millions par an en france pour tous
les établissements parce que comme c'est
très ciblées et donc quand on a des
stocks qui font des centaines de
millions au départ et puis qui sont
quand même à 75 millions en 60 en 2015
et qui sont de 750 milles en 2016
voilà donc peut-être qu'il faudrait
maintenir des stocks moi je dis c'est
une piste qui peut être examinée mais
voilà ce que nous avons excusez-moi si
madame la présidente juste une précision
vous avez donc personnellement suivi
c'est tout à votre honneur a d'ailleurs
le cette question du nombre de masse
puisque vous dites j'ai commandé vous
utilisez le pronom personnel dont vous
vous étiez directement oui oui non mais
vous étiez au nom voilà donc excusez-moi
alam la présidente
une façon de répondre à la question de
boris vallot je vais pas vous dire parce
que ce serait faux que je regardais au
jour le jour
l'état de tous les stocks c'est la
direction générale de la santé qui dans
les points
dans les rendez vous habituels que
j'avais mais où on parlait de qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire sur le tabac est-ce que
lutherie score ça avance est ce qu on
fait ceci ou est-ce qu'on fait pas cela
est ce qu'on prend en charge tel
dispositif pour le contre le sida enfin
vous pouvez imaginer là donc au milieu
de tout ça si j'ose dire mais à un point
identifié
il y avait la question des stocks et
c'est là où je vous ai dit que ce qui
m'est remonter très explicitement et où
on m'a demandé de me prononcer
c'est
les achats conjoint d'antigrippaux au
niveau européen
le tamiflu pour la grippe la variole et
de trouver des modes de financements
pour faire face aux ressources enfin
voilà et on ne m'a jamais dit madame la
ministre
est ce que vous nous autoriser est-ce
que vous m'autorisez à ne plus acheter
de masques ou voilà et donc c'est cette
discussion une fois que j'avais donné le
la ligne les arbitrages se faisait dans
des réunions opérationnelle entre la dgs
et santé publique france ou avant
l'eprus où ils évaluent est la manière
dont il fallait prioriser si vous passez
l'expression les différents achats etc
si le dgs avait le sentiment que danser
priorisation il y avait un enjeu
politique qui devait être tranchée que
cela me remontait et j'ai toujours fait
confiance je le dis j'ai toujours fait
confiance à benoît valais avant lui à
jean yves grall mais j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec benoît valait j'ai
toujours fait confiance à benoît valais
parce que il était d'une extrême rigueur
et surtout il avait le sens de ce qui
relevait de la technique opérationnel et
ce qui relevait de la décision politique
et pour répondre à monsieur le député
vallot je n'imagine pas que la
destruction
de stock significatif
je vous dis pas deux millions cinq
millions peut-être je sais pas parce que
il ya un pharmacien en chef c'est ça
qu'il ya un pharmacien en chef a pas
santé publique france à l'eprus qui est
une personnalité très très remarquable
très très très professionnel et qui fait
tout ce travail là et qu'ils regardent
et qui sort si j'ose dire des choses qui
en rentrent et c'est bon je pense je me
trompe peut-être je pense pas me tromper
je pense que si benoît valais avait pris
la décision de détruire
admettons
50 millions de sérum variolique il m'en
aurait parlé alors sur les ars excusez
moi juste a contrario est ce qui vous
paraît concevable que pendant trois ans
ministre de la santé qui vous a succédé
n'ai jamais eu la moindre information ni
son cabinet un c'est ce qui nous a été
dit hier sur le stock de masques
stratégique qu'est ce que ça vous paraît
concevable compte tenu de votre
expérience précédente
compte tenu de mon expérience de
l'organisation de l'état je pense que
chaque ministre à son fonctionnement et
chaque gouvernement à son organisation
et qu' on ne peut ne sais pas comment il
fonctionnait je vous le demande et moi
ce que je peux vous répondre c'est que
si ça c'était passé avec moi je me
serais fâché très très fort voilà et
ceux qui me connaissent savent que quand
je me fâche très très fort ça s'entend
voilà je ne peux que vous dire ça
maintenant
il y a aussi la question de savoir
quelle est la délégation que l'on fait
peut-être que moi j'ai fait des
délégations de compétence ou de
responsabilité au dgs ou au dg os ou à
la dss que mal successeur n'a pas fait
et sur des sujets sur lesquels elle
souhaitait avoir un regard direct
j'ai répondu à sur la question des
masques deux questions auxquelles je
n'ai pas eu à répondre encore la
question du financement de l'eprus donc
l'eprus a bénéficié de vous trouverez
tout ça dans le rapport delattre qui est
d'ailleurs extrêmement élogieux
contrairement à ce que j'ai lu sur la
création de santé publique france et qui
m'appelle en 2015 à faire des économies
sur les bruce donc je viens c'est assez
drôle
aujourd'hui on invoque le rapport
delattre pour me dire comment vous
n'avez pas mis assez d'argent mais plus
sérieusement au moment de la grippe h1n1
il y a eu des dotations financières
extrêmement importante à l'eprus qui
n'ont pas été consommés
lorsque je suis arrivé la décision qui a
été prise n'est pas de réduire le budget
elle a été
de réduire les dotations etat sécurité
sociale et de consommer les fonds de
roulement il y avait des fonds de
roulement absolument considérables et
donc chaque année le rapport delattre le
dit très bien les dépenses de l'eprus
sont supérieurs aux dotations qui lui
proviennent de l'état et de la sécurité
sociale parce qu'ils consomment des
réserves est en bonne gestion là je me
sentais aussi comptable des finances
publiques et de la bonne gestion
publique je le dis tout être ministre
c'est aussi se préoccuper de la question
des déficits de la question des budgets
de la question de l'organisation et de
la soutenabilité des politiques parce
que c'est trop facile de dire on va
faire ceci ceci cela et ne pas avoir de
financement à la clé les les les fonds
de roulement ont diminué mais les
budgets ont été les dépenses ont été
maintenues alors j'ai entendu je réponds
à ça peut-être par avance mais qu' on
pouvait s'interroger sur le fait que le
budget est passé il y avait double
dotation sécurité sociale et a alors je
vais vous dire très franchement je crois
que ça a changé d'ailleurs il y avait
2,2 arguments pour moi le premier c'est
que c'était très compliqué que les
cofinancements je trouve c'est très
compliqué pas uniquement dans ce domaine
là donc j'ai trouvé que c'était voilà
j'ai suivi une recommandation qui
m'était faite
et puis je le budget de la sécurité
sociale augmente est plus que le budget
de l'état et j'ai pensé que c'était une
manière de sanctuariser les fonds de
l'eprus et pour tout vous dire
la direction de la sécurité sociale de
mon ministère n'était pas chaude pas
enthousiastes à l'idée que je fasse
basculer le financement du côté de la
sécu plutôt que de le garder du côté de
l'état donc c'était ça partait peut-être
qu'il ne fallait pas le faire après tout
c'est des décisions techniques ne peut
regarder mais en tout cas de mon point
de vue ça partait de l'idée que c'était
une façon de protéger les financements
de l'eprus sur la question des lits
madame la députée je vous dirai les
choses très simplement
pendant les cinq ans où j'ai été
ministre
il y a eu une
légère augmentation du nombre de lits en
médecine 735 je me base sur des
documents officiels publics qui sont
ceux de l'adresse et vous pouvez
comparer les documents entre 2011 et
2017 ou 2011-2016 2012-2017 y en a à
chaque année il y a eu sur les lits de
réanimation une stabilisation il y avait
six mille deux cents lits de réanimation
en 2009
4800 en 2012 5000 en 2013
et ils sont restés à 5000 ensuite je ne
reviens pas c'est une question à part la
question de la manière dont on
comptabilise les lits de réanimation
parce que là j'ai entendu madame du
butin hier je ne peux que souscrire ces
propos il y a des manières différentes
de compte et l'allemagne la
grande-bretagne ne compte pas les lits
de réanimation de la même manière que la
france qui était un peu compliquée du
point de vue français à mon avis donc ça
on pourrait peut-être changer mais il
faut il faut ajouter pardon aux lits de
réanimation des lits de soins intensifs
et de surveillance avancé donc voilà
donc légère augmentation en médecine
stabilisation stabilité en réanimation
et baisse d'environ 10 11 mille lits de
chirurgie au profit de la chirurgie
ambulatoire et c'est une évolution que
j'assume
alors philippe vigier pour liberté
territoire merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre
moi ya une chose n'arrive pas à
comprendre mais comme d'autres ont posé
cette question s'est durablement qui a
été votre conseiller qui fait de notre
président de la république qui lui
donnait pas protégions n'est pas prêt ce
qu'à un moment ou un autre il nous a
fait passer dé courrier dans lequel il
vous a dit la madame la ministre ne va
pas là dû sûrement danger là il faut
prendre des décisions
est ce que oui ou non ces courriers aux
as et adresse crise qui a des traces ou
est-ce que simplement il est resté dans
un mail qu'il a préparé pour le candidat
à la présidence de la république c'est
important pour qu'on comprenne veux pas
revenir sur twitter des masques on
comprendrait bien dans l'opinion
publique lorsqu'un jour a misé la
république le 10 des mac ne servent à
rien c'est pas obligatoire puis le
lendemain il faut les utiliser dans le
bal pas de vous dans l'opinion publique
naturellement cela se met 2
et moi la seconde chose est ce qu'à un
moment ou un autre des raisons
budgétaires vous avez en partie répondu
là on guide et vos choix stratégiques ou
pas est-ce que vous avez été empêchée
pour des raisons budgétaires de définir
une stratégie et de la mettre en
application
la troisième chose sur les agences tout
à l'heure en question je crois de jean
christophe lagarde
on sait qu' il y avait des stocks
décentraliser ce que vous et dans les
ars ont bien fait remonter justement ces
quantités parce qu'on s'est aperçu sur
le terrain maison vous connaissez bien
que les stocks étaient extrêmement
différent et pas que de masquer de
l'ensemble des matériels de protection
et comment expliquez-vous notamment que
sur les antiviraux on nous a annoncé
qu'avec 95% qui était périmé qu'on
n'arrive pas à comprendre
quatrième sur dur y était ministre
lorsque cette crise est arrivée
comment auriez vous ressenti l'arrivée
du comité scientifique est ce que pour
vous ce comité scientifique dont
j'estime qu'il a fait un bon travail et
ce n'est pas justement le signe que les
agences n'ont pas été à la hauteur on a
le sentiment au terme de quelques
auditions qui ont été conduites par la
présidente et rapporteur que tout ne
remonte pas jusqu'à la ministre qui a
une sorte d'opacité une sorte
d'incompréhension et quelque part c'est
la politique publique qui en fait est là
dessus pour terminer dernière chose vous
auriez prendre à prendre une décision
sur youtube cyclo dur pendant hydroxy
chloroquine qu'auriez-vous pris comme
décision
merci beaucoup merci pierre dharréville
pour le gt r oui merci madame la
présidente
peut-être première question mais ça
recoupe et une partie de ce que vient de
dire philippe vigier avez vous eu
connaissance de la note de jérôme
salomon qui est paru en un peuple qui
l'a envoyé en 2016 au candidat emmanuel
macron en avez vous été destinataire en
avez vous eu connaissance première
question deuxième question parmi les
points d'attention vous avez transmis
lors de la transition avec agnès buzyn
lorsqu'elle vous a succédé au ministère
est ce qu'il ya des points d'attention
que vous l'avez transmis qui avait très
justement la gestion de ce type de crise
telle que nous la connaissions qui
entraient la discussion que que nous
avons là
ensuite sur l'organisation de la gestion
des stocks on a du mal à comprendre
comment il était géré et comment était
organisé finalement la gestion y compris
ceux de la péremption des stocks jeudi
une grande partie des stocks sur
laquelle on vous disait qu'il n'y avait
pas de date de péremption
ça peut s'entendre de deux façons le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas de date de
péremption
ça peut être un problème parce qu'on
sait que ça péri mais on ne sait pas
quand et ça peut être le fait que ces
masques sont pérennes donc ça soulève
des questions est-ce qu'elles ont été
évoqués les avez vous évoqué n'y at il
pas un problème d'organisation
effectivement des agences de la santé à
faire un certain nombre d' agences mais
du coup l'action publique quelque part
les responsabilités sont peut-être un
peu diluée est ce que c'est le sentiment
que vous avez comment vous regardez
cette chose-là les moyens de santé
publique france ont été réduits
puisqu'ils ont ils avaient déjà été
réduits de 10% et de 10% supplémentaires
est ce que à vos yeux ce n'est pas un
problème
vous avez cité une phrase d'un document
il appartient aux employeurs de
constituer des stocks
est-ce que ça n'aurait pas nécessité et
y at il un dispositif de ce type au
ministère de s'assurer de la capacité de
production et pas simplement
d'approvisionnement sur un certain
nombre de produits et de matériels de
protection est ce qu'il ya des
dispositifs qui existent en la matière
et enfin je termine par la sueur les
stocks des hôpitaux
y at il un dispositif de contrôle il
fait que ces stocks étaient bien
constituées
merci simplement quelques observations
il ya une confusion entre l'avis du haut
conseil de santé publique en 2011 qui
est un avis demandé par votre
prédécesseur et la directive de 2013 qui
est signé par la direction de générale
de la défense sur la vie du premier
ministre et qu'est le 16 mai 2013 c'est
cette directive la qui s'applique
avant c'était un avis deuxième
observation
je suis d'accord vous avez stabilisé à
environ 750 millions de masques chaque
année mais pourquoi brutalement
on arrive à en détruire 350 360 millions
dé votre départ en 2018
pourquoi parce que vous nous il nous
faudrait avoir chaque année exactement
les commandes que vous avez exercé
pendant depuis 2012 jusqu'en 2017
troisième observation
c'est au niveau de l'eprus nous l'avons
voté
l'intégration à son santé publique
france nous l'avons voté mais nous
avions fait des recommandations qui
étaient des recommandations aussi bien
au sénat qu'à l'assemblée de dire qu'il
fallait mettre le peuple et à en en
condition de défense en cas de menace
sanitaire
il y a eu une recommandation early qui
était le comité technique de l'eprus qui
a donné un avis le 14 avril 2016
personnes en a eu connaissance
il serait intéressant d'avoir le
document du comité technique de l'eprus
pour savoir quel était son avis au
moment où il ya eu l'intégration de
l'eprus au sein de santé publique franck
merci merci jean jacques gauthier un
préalable aux dames la ministre comme
pour tout ministre de la santé vous êtes
responsable de la décision d'acquisition
et de renouvellement des masques
alors on a beaucoup parlé des doctrines
de gestion des masques de 2011 2013
en fait ce qui compte c'est est ce qu'il
y a des masques combien pour qui et où
tout le reste c'est de la littérature
alors si la doctrine ne change pas la
quantité de masques change 2012 début du
ministère ont étaient 800 milliards de
masques chirurgicaux et 600 millions de
ff p2 donc 1 milliard 400 millions de
masques en 2017
nous tombons à 750 millions de masques
chirurgicaux
quand on masque ffp2 il ya un doute donc
on baisse à la fois en quantité et en
qualité en quantité on est quasiment
divisé par deux et en qualité qu'en est
il des masques ffp2 combien exactement
de masques ffp2 en 2017
avez-vous donc poussé au renouvellement
des stocks de masques ffp2 avez vous
vérifié l'état des stocks de masques
ffp2 y at il eu un monitoring des stocks
en ce qui concerne des stocks d'état
mais aussi une vérification des stocks
dans les hôpitaux dans les ehpad
c'est s'il ya eu un transfert de
compétences vers les hôpitaux les ehpad
pour ses stocks
est-ce que ce transfert de compétence
est accompagné d'un transfert de
finances et avez vous évoqué ces
questions des stocks avec le président
de la république on a entendu monsieur
hollande dire qu'il assumait sa part de
responsabilité avez vous évoqué cette
question avec le président de la
république et avec le premier ministre
dernier point sur un autre domaine sur
les plates formes cette plateforme
génomique importante pour la recherche y
compris sur le coup vide le pré ministre
valls à l'époque avait voulu lancer un
appel à projets sur 12 plateforme
génomique sous l'égide de votre
ministère de la santé en décembre 2016
l'appel à projets national ne concernait
plus que deux plateformes génomique qui
durait sont encore très peu
opérationnels et aujourd'hui la france
est complètement déclassé bien loin
derrière l'angleterre même la hollande
la grèce le portugal
c'est important pour la recherche du coc
vide et pour toutes les maladies
génétiques
là aussi votre ministère est directement
concernée merci monsieur julien aubert
merci madame la ministre vous avez
expliqué que vous aviez été notamment
pilote sur le plan hors scène épi vac
qui est l'ancêtre du plan orsec réd
celui qui donc concerne les risques
épidémiologiques
quand je prends la version du guide
méthodologique en ligne sur le site du
ministère aide à l'organisation de
l'offre de soin en situation sanitaire
exceptionnel donc de 2014
je ne trouve pas une fois le mot masque
il est uniquement précisé une seule fois
en page 73 soit quatre pages en annexe
du document et on parle d'équipements de
protection dédiée où on explique que les
établissements de santé doivent avoir
des équipements de protection dédiée
sans spécifier d'ailleurs quel type de
moyens de protection
quand je le compare avec le plan horse
and web qui date de 2020 je trouve en
revanche cinq mentions dans le document
extrêmement précise expliquant le type
de masque comment est-ce qu'on doit les
traiter les stocker les jeter etc
la question est très simple est ce que
vous pensez ne pensez pas que le plan
orsec et hippie vague que vous avez
piloté en réalité fait l'impasse ce
sujet des masques est ce que c'est
normal
et est ce que ce n'est pas ça ne referai
pas plutôt une culture de lagence à
défaut d'avoir une culture de l'urgence
merci et josiane corneloup merci même la
présidente madame la ministre je
voudrais revenir sur trois points
le premier concerne 7
cette décision de secrétariat général à
la défense nationale en 2013 qui décide
que la responsabilité de constituer des
stocks de masques incombera désormais
aux employeurs qu'ils soient privés ou
publics c'est donc un changement majeur
vous nous dites en même temps que cette
décision n'est pas une obligation et que
c'est simplement si les employeurs
privés au public le souhaite
comment imaginer qu'un stock stratégique
repose sur une décision
pardon comment imaginer qu'un stock
stratégique repose sur le volontariat
vous explique également que les masques
étaient rangés dans des dans un lieu
extrêmement sens et pourtant les masques
sont moisis
comment est ce possible et puis une
troisième question comment peut-on
justifier selon vous l'interdiction
prescriptions de la chloroquine par les
médecins libéraux
je vous remercie
merci alors damas ministre vu le nombre
de questions voilà je vous laisse le
temps de répondre très très parce qu'il
ya des questions auxquelles j'ai déjà
répondu non la doctrine de 2013 ne vente
pas du sgdn la responsabilité des
employeurs à l'égard de leurs salariés
je regrette cette responsabilité est
inscrite dans le code du travail
depuis 2007 je vous ai cités tout à
l'heure les articles
c'est une ordonnance qui a été ratifiée
au parlement et sa part est d'ailleurs
logique ça s'applique aux employeurs
privés comme aux employeurs publics et
le sgdn a d'ailleurs adressé une note à
tous les ministères en tout cas au
ministère de la santé pour lui demander
comment il entendait assumer la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de ses agents
c'est à dire les gens qui travaillent au
ministère de la de là
sentez donc il n'y a pas eu je suis
désolé il n'y a pas de changement de
conception et d'ailleurs personne ne le
dit comme ça et personne ne le conçois
comme cela c'est aux hôpitaux si on en
vient ou aux employeurs de d'avoir leur
stock de masques masques chirurgicaux ou
masques ffp2 ces masques ne font pas
partie des stocks stratégiques justement
c'est à dire que la doctrine de 2011
elle dit voilà ce qu'il ya sur les
masques 1 parce qu'il ya par ailleurs
dans les stocks stratégiques c'est ce
que je vous disais il ya une quarantaine
de produits des comprimés diodes je veux
pas revenir les antiviraux etc etc
mais sur les masques il y a
principalement des masques chirurgicaux
il est indiqué que les masques ffp2 ne
sont plus nécessaires et donc ils
décroissent en 2012 monsieur le député
moi je trouve 730 millions de masques
chirurgicaux il a dû y en avoir qui
était consommée entre les deux c'est
voilà 730 millions et les ffp2 et ffp2
ils vont ils vont diminuer
progressivement une à 75 millions encore
en 2014 ou 2015 pardon de la précision
et c'est en 2016 où il n'en reste plus
que 750 milles et donc ce ne sont pas
des stocks stratégiques ce sont des
stocks qui ne sont même pas des stocks
tactique
ce sont des stocks qui sont constitués
par les établissements de référence par
les employeurs et d'ailleurs les
hôpitaux où ces stocks là pour faire
face à leurs activités habituelles faire
qu'il ya des opérations dans les
hôpitaux et donc il faut bien qu'ils
aient enfin certaines opérations
certains actes qui requiert qu'il y ait
ces masques là sur le comité technique
de l'eprus monsieur d'or je ne sais pas
ce qu'il dit dans toutes les dents dans
les débats auxquels nous participions à
l'époque j'ai dit que j'avais et je les
ai écrit dans la lettre de mission à
monsieur bourdillon que je lui demandais
de faire la fusion entre les agences
existantes avec la plus grande vigilance
vis-à-vis des salariés parce que c'est
ça le comité technique
c'est dans quelles sont les conditions
sociales dans lesquelles va se réaliser
la fusion et il y avait évidemment des
inquiétudes étaient franchement vous
avez trois agences pour leur histoire
leur culture et qui se disent mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer on va leur
demander à certaines de changer
d'endroit puisqu'une partie des
économies est venue de la
rationalisation immobilière il y avait
des sites différents ils ont été
regroupées en un seul site donc c'est ça
l'enjeu du comité technique mais alors
sur la sueur sur la qualité des masques
moi je comprends bien il ya là pour le
coup le monitoring com
l'un d'entre vous l'a dit il relève de
l'eprus plus de santé publique france
qui doit faire remonter une alerte la
leyre n'est pas remonté en tout cas elle
n'est pas remonté jusqu'à moi elle n'est
pas remonté moi je ne peux pas inventer
je ne peins je j'ajoute que dans le même
temps tout le monde jean cys tout le
monde considérait ou en tous cas me
disais que les masques n'avait pas de
date de péremption
il y a eu des destructions de masquer
certains lots qui devaient être détruits
ne l'ont pas été de manière fortuite je
reviens pas sur les raisons pour
lesquelles c'est intervenus c'est dire
le bon côté de du mauvais côté de la
sphère lubrizol clairement puisque l'
usine de destruction de masse qui était
situé à côté et donc d'une catastrophe
est issu quelque chose de relativement
positifs des démos qui devaient être
détruits ne le sont pas et à ce moment
là il y à une nouvelle étude
une nouvelle évaluation qui est fait par
la dg a et qui dit ces masques peuvent
être utilisés destination du grand
public
or je vous rappelle quand même que la
doctrine de 2011
elle considère que les masques ils vont
à destination du grand public ce qu'elle
appelle la population générale
donc au fond je hais ce qu'il y avait
des lots qui était pourri monsieur je
sais plus qui a posé la question
monsieur d'or moi j'étais pas là tu t'es
pas dans les entrepôts donc je ne vais
pas en ayant juré vous dire il y avait
100 % de l'eau réutilisables je n'en
sais rien mais ce dont je suis certaine
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas 100 % de l'eau
à jeter et d'ailleurs vous le savez fort
bien vous dans vos mairies ou dans vos
collectivités conseils départementaux ou
dans des entreprises que vous connaissez
il ya eu des dons il ya eu des dons de
masques qui datait de la même période et
qui ont été utilisés qui ont été
utilisés mais qui ont été utilisés dans
les ehpad donner à des médecins
libero donner à des salariés dans des
camps avaient besoin dans des hôpitaux
moi j'ai lu dans la presse que madame
hidalgo avait donné un million je crois
de masques à l'ap-hp dont elle dit elle
même qu'ils étaient périmés donc ça veut
dire que le fait d'être périmés ne rend
pas impropre à tout et c'est ça que je
veux vous dire pour je ne porte je ne
parle pas de la période postérieure à
je parle de la période qui est la mienne
c'est que à partir du moment où on a des
masques qui sont vérifiées monitorer et
dont on nous dit ils peuvent être
utilisés
on se dit on peut compter sur ces masses
sur jérôme salomon jérôme salomon il est
parti de mon cabinet en 2016 il m'a
informé qu'il soutiendrait la
candidature de à l'époque de monsieur
macron je suis quelqu'un de démocrates
chacun y avait dans mon cabinet des gens
qui ensuite d'ailleurs ont soutenu des
candidats avec différents et pas
simplement ils n'avaient pas simplement
le choix entre deux vous dire donc ils
ont soutenu des candidats différents
non il ne m'a pas informé de cette note
dont j'ai pris connaissance dans la
presse et nous avons régulièrement je
voulais déjà dit évoquer la question de
la sq qui nous paraissait être un point
de la nécessité d' acculturés c'est moi
ce terme un peu pédant meda culture et
les administrations
toutes les administrations à une culture
de l'urgence et de l'exception je vous
ai répondu monsieur le député vigier sur
les antiviraux sur le comité
scientifique
moi je pense que c'était plutôt une
bonne idée d'avoir des personnalités
reconnues ça ne peut qu'aider ça ne peut
que soutenir je ne le moi
personnellement si j'avais été ministre
je ne l'aurais pas pris comme une
comment dire une mise en cause ou quoi
que ce soit je l'aurais pris comme
quelque chose qui vient accompagner la
la la la décision et vous dites on a le
sentiment que tout ne remontent pas
enfin honnêtement sur le député
heureusement parce que sinon c'est la
thrombose et je pense même qu'il ne faut
pas que tout remonte je pense qu'être
ministre c'est savoir trier les
informations et donné des consignes
claires à ceux qui travaillent avec vous
sur ce qui doit être
ce qui doit remonter et ce qui ne doit
pas remonter
il m'est arrivé que des collaborateurs
ne fasse pas remonter des décisions
importantes que je mange considérée
comme importante qu'il était et il
considérait que c'était technique je
peux vous dire qu'ils se souviennent
encore
ils se souviennent encore de la manière
dont j'ai réagi parce que c'est
inadmissible
voilà moi je suis très carré monsieur le
député dharréville non je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient trop d'agencés peut-être
qu'on peut encore faire des
regroupements peut-être là honnêtement
pour être très honnête ça fait trois ans
que je ne regarde plus sa très près je
ne crois pas à l'idée d'une super
structure parce qu'il ya un moment où
les superstructures ça fait super
structure si vous voilà donc je
terminerai par les questions madame
connu monsieur gautier est ce que je
vous ai répondu le député aubert je
crois vous avoir pas moi monsieur le
député
vous m'avez parlé dit les masques en
2020 oui alors le plan le plan b à
écouter moi je suis très humble très
humble là dessus je suis sûr d'avoir
fait que des documents techniques qui
sont sortis pendant ma période étaient
meilleurs que ceux de la période d'avant
que ceux de la période d'avant étaient
meilleurs que ceux de la période
d'encore avant etc et heureusement qu'on
apprend je veux dire le monde ne
s'arrête pas de tourner et voilà on
progresse donc si le 6 le guide 2020 est
meilleur que le guide 2014
je m'en réjouis parce qu on a commencé
on a expérimenté
c'était le premier et après il ya des
retours et puis on se dit bah voilà
c'est pas comme ça chez passé dans votre
vie vous fait toujours tout bien du
premier coup vraiment chapeau donc vous
me direz comment vous faites mériterait
une commission donc
nous avons évoqué la question de stocks
stratégiques lorsqu il y a eu beau là
j'ai eu un nombre très important de des
changes avec le président hollande et
avec le premier ministre mais nous ne
parions pas uniquement des stocks
stratégiques nous parlions aussi de la
façon de gérer notre nom notre soutien
le fait d'envoyer des hôpitaux de
campagne
en guinée de soigner nous avions la
politique de soigner tous ceux qui
travaillaient pour des ong de les
rapatrier en france pour les soigner ce
qui n'était pas le choix d'autres pays
qui disaient qu'ils se débrouillent sur
place tu t'es quand même pas selon nous
extrêmement grandiose est là aussi pour
ebola monsieur le député lescure avait
il ya beaucoup à dire sur la relation
avec l'union européenne
donc si moi je ne vais pas vous dire que
il n'ya pas des moments où j'aurais
souhaité obtenir davantage de moyens
bien sûr que j'aurais souhaité obtenir à
certains moments davantage de moyens et
que j'ai demandé davantage de moyens
pour un certain nombre d'actions mais je
ne suis pas certaine qu'ils aient
beaucoup de ministres qui n'est pas ce
sentiment mais moi j'ai demandé des
moyens qui ont été données pour certains
moins pour d'autres et je crois que
lorsque le président hollande s'est
exprimé il pensait à la question de la
rémunération des personnels soignant à
l'hôpital et j'ai moi même dit que voilà
mais voilà je ne peux que vous répondre
que en ce qui me concerne je n'ai pas
évoqué la question des masques avec le
président hollande
et pour tout vous dire il me semble
préférable que ce genre de discussion
n'ait pas lieu avec le président de la
république mais c'est peut-être ma
conception de la présidence de la
république et du ministre et de la
relation de loyauté d'un ministre à
l'égard de son président de la
république je peux avoir eu des
désaccords avec le président de la
république ne pas avoir obtenu ce que je
souhaitais obtenir du président de la
république
j'ai été sa ministre et ma loyauté lui
est acquise
seul à porter n'est plus deux hommes
simplement peut-être
hier nous avons évoqué le recours à des
cabinets d'audit à la fois pour la
restructuration des structures
hospitalières mais façon peut-être un
peu plus étonnantes sur la gestion de la
crise sur l'organisation de la crise
notamment sur la capacité de notre pays
à mettre en place des tests qui faisait
défaut au début de début de la crise
est-ce que vous personnellement vous
avez eu recours à ces cabinets d'audit
si oui dans quel cadre pas vous répondre
de manière dont je suis je sois certaine
qu'elle soit exhaustive
j'ai le souvenir d'une fois où j'ai eu
recours fin j'ai eu recours une de mes
direction a eu recours à un cabinet
extérieur parce que dans un délai
extrêmement rapprochés
j'ai demandé une réorganisation complète
de la structuration du budget c'est à
dire du budget de la sécurité sociale
car qui mettait présenté avec un certain
nombre de choses
peu importe et moi j'ai dit je trouve
que ça n'est pas compréhensible pour
l'opinion publique il faut que le budget
soit structurée en fonction de priorités
qui soit clairement identifié par
l'opinion publique et ça a l'air simple
de dire ça mais en réalité les lignes
d'un budget c'est vous savez tous
extrêmement compliqué et compte tenu des
délais dont nous disposions la direction
de la sécurité sociale m'a demandé
l'autorisation de se faire appuyé par un
cabinet financier
à ma connaissance c'est la seule fois
mais comme je suis sous serment je ne
voudrais pas prendre le risque
d'apprendre que ça a été le cas d'autres
reprises mais c'est le cas qui me vient
à l'esprit venait d'écouter l'audition
de marisol touraine qui a expliqué qu'à
son départ en 2017 il y avait bien 750
millions de masques en stock mais
qu'elle n'avait jamais changer la
doctrine commandant d'en avoir un
milliard elle a également précisé qu'à
aucun moment elle n'avait été averti du
très mauvais état de ce stock de masques
cette audition et toutes celles menées
par la commission denquête sont à revoir
tout l'été sur lcp et sur notre site
lcp point fr